wait ruston said on stream that i'm his
favorite i am
really
maybe that's not too surprising we are
um
whenever he's in st louis we we play
tennis
if you have a clip of that send me a
clip
eric rosen my favorite i am
hans nemont i don't know him
that's still um that's very flattering
though
there's a lot of ions on the planet
i think what i'll do is i will play
chess
i'm gonna join this tournament and this
will be more chill
i'm not really trying to win because i'm
joining very late
i'm joining about 15 minutes late but
i'll try and just play decent moves
oh i have zen mode let me do a pull
keep zen mode yes
no okay
uh for now i'll keep zen mode also i
probably misspelled yes and no
but that's okay i have no idea who i'm
playing i'm probably
playing someone actually i don't know
the first game
i could be playing anyone i guess i'll
try and guess the rating
oh people want zen mode
oh but it's really close so zenmo just
hides information
about my opponents okay my opponent's
probably rated like 1600
i was a failed fork
just gonna go for the mate oh knight f1
defends
but these center pawns are so nice
oh uh does this work
i guess it works
a free queen i'm still going for mates
opponent doesn't want to get mated
okay let's do this
okay okay 1742
oh wow no wins by by one vote
wow that was the closest poll ever i'll
turn off zen mode then
or maybe maybe i'll stream half the
games in zen mode
half the game not in zen mode that would
be too complicated though
um okay i guess i'll move on
and once the next game starts i'll press
z to deactivate zen mode
or do do zen mode until i lose a game i
like that i actually like that better
that's a good compromise and then i
won't do it the rest of the stream
so um yes slight change of plans
i'll keep trying to guess my opponent's
rating
okay for a4 is like a 1500 move
um if i want to take that
let's play h5 it's a typical move in
these structures
so we kind of have like a reverse french
structure
this knight is now pinned interesting
i'm gonna take and then take
yeah king f1 was not working
threatening this i'm guessing about 1500
white should have played rook c1 earlier
white has one legal move
but a few a few different ways to lose
what can resign
like in flag or white can
probably proceed to get mated oh
actually once i take the queen it's a
it's a triple fork
every move is a capture oh can i
queenside castle with mate
how do i orchestrate this
it's difficult
um i want a queenside castle with meat
ah the knight's in the way
go back to d1
okay oh i was playing a 2200 oh
oh that i guess my my guesstimate was
kind of insulting then
did i have knight a1 oh i had knight a1
check
at some point probably
okay i gained one rating point
so knight before in long castle the
issue was
this nikon block that's why i played g5
i never got my chance at castle the
final position i can still
use that here i can still legally castle
both sides
alright back to tournaments
so zen mode continues
okay
have i been black every game so far i
think i have
stafford gambit declined
okay i feel like i'm playing a stronger
player here
yeah white's playing some decent moves
also playing quickly too
i just lose a pawn i think i lost a pawn
white didn't take it though
i like the position pieces are
kind of clustered oh i miss that
let's take this
offering or queen trade let's move back
so i'm down the pawn i'm guessing like
probably 2300
or stronger maybe i don't know losing
another pawn
or am i of knight c7 tactics
queen f3 i take takes and then bishop
here wins the queen
i'm stopping queen h4 too
okay now i'm guessing like 2 000 because
my opponents
should not miss that oh 1900 okay
yeah a stronger player would um
would try and fight on differently
anyway um
opponent played well i played the
opening quickly and
solidly i think my pawn was hanging
here
no i can't count oh no it was hanging
here
yeah four attackers maybe there are some
tricks with the c file though
so it wasn't so obvious i should make a
5d chest command explaining
that i've not played it oh okay
just for you very weird name commands
add
5d i
haven't yet played
5d chess
what do we consider this chess 2d or 3d
because of course it's a 2d board but
when you add time
that's like a third dimension
but then i guess over the board chess
would be 4d chess i don't know
yeah i feel like when you add time you
have to increase the
dimension by one all right so another
zen mo i'm
i've been black every game this stream
this is my fourth black game in a row
i guess i'm getting used to it
what is this opening
okay i'm guessing like 1300 this is a
weird opening
it's confusing me though i have to play
accurately because my opponent could
just be secretly
maybe a gm but probably not oh that's a
good move
okay let's i'm i'm okay though
okay i'm guessing 1300
okay i blundered upon
[Music]
oh white blunders and knight maybe 1200
i'm threatening oh i'm throwing
queenside castle with meat
let's go oh 9 9 67.
queen side castling with mate
i wasn't really anticipating it just
kind of worked out really nicely
the king the white king was kind of
smothered
you've probably been black all stream
because your shirt is black
oh i'm i'm wearing a ali chess shirt
you can go to leachate.org swag and buy
clothing
to support the website
i don't think i've ever had
a game less than 20 moves where i cancel
with mate
so that's probably youtube worthy oh do
i have to tag this with ad
this isn't sponsored by lee chess
this is basically lee chess is sponsored
by
by us right
um anyway if you're watching in the
future on youtube
hope you enjoyed that beware of the
opponent's castling
but also checkmating okay
that was a slightly it was a very
symmetrical opening
but when white plays d3 d4 it's giving
me the extra tempo
and then that was nice set my knight
controls e6
okay let's go back so working my way up
so the problem with zen mode it's too
risky to berserk
because i could be playing a really
strong player so i'm just gonna hold off
on berserking
black for like a sixth time right
i'm gonna have to go to my profile and
see i
have not been white this this stream
okay we have a scotch this time i'll
play this um
weird variation goose
with 100 bits oh f3 is the best move
bishop b5 was battery for white this is
kind of an equal position
[Music]
g7 coming
so i have double pawns white has
isolated e pawn i have a half open file
but so does white
i could have won maybe upon i don't know
though
probably better not to take that oh i
could have won this pawn though
no i can't the rook's defended by the
bishop
oh that's a free bishop i'm guessing
probably
1500 maybe 1400
why played the opening solidly though
hmm
i'll say 1500
attacking this pawn
okay now i'm just going for meat
probably take i'll take with the pawn
hey i think that was my best guess of
today
yeah how many games so one two three
four five oh so these are all the games
so i've played five games on stream
today
every single game i'm black so i wonder
i wonder if it's just random i assumed
that
like if you've been black a certain
number of games in a row
then you're more likely to be white
but i don't know let's go back
i'm sure someone someone probably knows
like the algorithm
actually it's open source so people
people can probably find it somewhere
lee chess doesn't want me to play london
oh okay now it's too late london time
opponents playing very quickly
i'm definitely playing a stronger player
i want to go for g4 g5
as a typical attacking idea especially
with h-file
usually the knight wants to come in to
some better square
go play g5 just immediately
so i could play this
i'm not meeting yet because the king's
going to run away
unless i can get a pawn to g6
yeah my my plan is neither knight to g5
and then mate
black has menacing pawns though i don't
think it matters
this is pretty unstoppable
a queen c3 i think was the only move to
delay mate
i'm disappointed now i didn't take
because if i take
this is a very rare situation where
black has triple pawns next to double
pawns
so there would be there would be
quintuple pawn potential
if we imagine like takes here here here
here let's check so here
here here this this could
be a theoretically possible position
not that i would go for that but
it's also a c
for for crab right
anyway back to tournaments hey top
thousand
so i'm only
only like probably 20 wins away from the
money
okay let's um let's play another london
so that worked pretty well oh c for
chess it's probably a better
a better word than crab
i don't think i've ever encountered e6
g6 against london
at least this early
i'm threatening this oh i could have
played that right away
i can still play it
is the queen getting trapped
queen's almost trapped okay let's take
this
the tables have turned i i now have the
fiance on g7
just keep developing i want to play e4
or i want to bring my knight here
or i want to win a pawn there's so many
things to do
yeah this is coming and then i'll try
and queen my h-pawn
yeah the pawn can't be stopped i forgot
to guess the rating
that was a fun game i probably would
have guessed a little bit lower but yeah
black calendar
under some pressure that came
yeah in general like you do have to be
careful when the h pawn
is pushed and you've committed to g6
like the typical ideas are either h6
h5 or knight f6 maybe h6 here
would be safe
so i have 24 points i would need to
finish
top three i'm i'm very far away from the
money about 46 minutes left
this is uh yeah this is a warm up so
anyone can play
but then starting in about 50 minutes
there will be the actual title arena
okay stafford gambit time
i think queen d6 is a move i've studied
this at some point
it's a fun kind of fishing pole idea
i'm guessing 1600 oh 2100
that was nice a stafford gambit is so
so dangerous especially in bullets
because it's so easy to like fall victim
to these
these sort of attacks the pawn is pinned
this is actually like one of the best
lines like d3 bishop e2
um here h3 is a safe move
or even c3 to prepare d4
okay back to tournaments moving up in
the world
oh almost an unlucky number feel bad for
bing bing boom
okay so zen mode staying on
i think my goal is to keep zen mode all
the way through the end of the the title
arena
so basically not to lose a game this
stream
it's going to get more difficult though
oops
did not mean to play that opponent's
going to play hippo
what is this what is this
just play this move
okay i'm gonna play queen e7 and go
after this pawn
there we go
yeah white basically employed like this
weird bullet opening
but is now facing the consequences
i guess like 2000
my mating very close to mating
where's my mate
chuck
not seeing my mate
i guess i can just do this
that was nice
yeah white's opening kind of confused me
i was trying to crack the position
i should play a4 here but then i was
gonna still attack
on the dark squares
okay another mystery opponent another
black game
oh we have like a kind of a carrot con
pan off type opening
it's an iqp position
oh i'm losing i'm losing a pawn
quincy too good move yeah i'm playing a
good player
oh but maybe i'm winning something and i
see two coming
come back
could trade queens
oh that was a bad move or was it
why has rooks he won
i'm not winning the exchange
that's unfortunate 195 hurts me
might misses it it's not the highest
quality game
okay now i'm winning this pawn i'm
guessing i'm playing like a 2200
some weird structure
okay that was probably the closest game
yet
of the stream um
yeah opponent actually played this
opening well i fell into a trap that
i've
i've played myself as white before
this um yeah this rookie one move is
very sneaky
because it basically after rookie 1 b6
white's winning a pawn
i'm pretty sure
i think i'm supposed to play bishop f6
here
yeah the problem is if i take with pawn
queen c2 hits this and this
and after this um
[Music]
again queen c2 hits this and this oh but
maybe i can take
no but then my rook's hanging
yeah okay recovered after
the opening trap
let's move on
why do i prefer leachates over chess.com
i feel like i've addressed this question
before
i play on both sides it's um i do like
the tools on the chests
but um yeah both sites have their their
pros and cons
and at least for today it's a title
arena so
there's a reason to play here
oh okay i'll take all the pawns i'll
take the rook too
what wow look at this e pawn
i mean i so that was a six move game
five of those moves i just moved the
same pawn
it was just a pawn rampage man
i'm regretting like just including d5
d5 was a loss of tempo if i knew i could
just storm down the diagonal
okay
419.
yeah it's going to be very hard to catch
up but
still moving upwards
i'm playing very quickly
my plan is knight g5
and be aggressive
i'm trying to go fishing
wow so e6 is hanging
i think i'll just take it and take on g7
or move back
click on g7
temporary triple pawns
yeah so i'm up a pawn i always play king
b1
so i want to play g4 breakthrough
rook g6 coming
black wants to play this move but it
doesn't really have time
threatening meat
oh i forgot to get some raining good
game though
that was fun
it can be scary when the opponent just
like pre-moves every move in the opening
but that was a pleasant like london
attack hey
it's holy grove it wins plus after
months of watching your streams and
playing the computer i played my
first literature
you're firstly chess human that's like a
monumental
moment uh good job
good luck in your your quest playing
more humans
thanks for the bits okay so here i'm
playing
hyper aggressive
um okay i want to play bishop d3
and then rook h1 is another kind of
attacking game
h6 i'll just take it
i'm guessing 1900 similar to my last
opponent
it's very close to mating preventing
king e8
and rook g3 coming
a queen g5 is the only legal move
not just below 2000 okay
i should have a goal i think the goal is
top
maybe top 100 can start with
oh the caution
i'm clicking yet
so i've lost counseling rights e5 is
[Music]
coming
hmm
i have a weird idea i'm going to play
bishop here i just want to prevent life
from castling
i'm giving back the peace
now we both can't castle
except i can fake castle
oh good move
hmm
okay attacking the knight i guess bishop
e3 is only move
that's a move too
wait checkmates okay
that was a weird game i feel like we
both
went wrong at various moments
so knight takes f7 is more common after
d6
i've actually had this before i wasn't
sure if i should play d5
because after takes takes there's this
move and then i have to play this
and it's kind of like a fried liver whoa
whoa holy grove gifting 10 subs thanks
so much
i just want to learn one lesson what to
do in this position
oh d5 it takes
ah queen e8 is a nice inclusion and then
okay
i'll remember this for next time thanks
holy grove
gifting subs to rock mania the big bad
chess
julian g and lad and c elsima
that reason though someone should make a
username that rosen though
neon siegel reluc superc kingmaker2313
and anmo noreen
appreciate it welcome to to all the new
subs
oh you're you're intoxicated
from your first win nice
yeah the first win in chess can be very
intoxicating
but then eventually you'll build up some
tolerance
hey 50 points 32 minutes left
so i joined well i joined about half
hour ago
so if i keep up the pace i can finish
with maybe over 100
but i'm gonna probably start playing
stronger players
oh it's a dutch let's play h3g4
like a stonewall
yes now i have the open open g file
i think i want to play c4 queen b3 and
target the king
along the diagonal maybe f32
so black wants to remove the knight
i guess i have to take it whoa
i'm intoxicated with from my first win
i do this move thanks again for the bits
holy grove
keep it up let's play queen b3
so probably want a castle
that's going to be some sharp position
my attack is actually kind of slower
than expected
i might want to go for this maneuver or
just a double up
attacking f5 if g6 i can play rook h1 h5
interesting let's take that
um
it's a little bit dangerous for both of
us
[Music]
hmm
oops
dirty flag time
okay so i was losing there
my my attack didn't work what happened
e4 was a bad move i just didn't know
what to do here
king g8 was a good move
a4 was coming yeah time saved me
why zen mode we have a poll
and slightly more than half of the
people
told me to turn off zen mode feeling hot
hot hot
oh thanks tom silver
uh so then i kind of compromised
that once i lose a game i'll turn off
zen mode for the rest of the stream
but i haven't lost a game yet
so this is my life now whoa it's two
dollars and twenty
years what's your favorite movie in the
cars franchise
i've been bored lately so i went on a
children's movie spree
oh i don't know if i've watched
cars also am i blundering a piece
there goes my bishop maybe there's some
conversation
i don't know it's castle
i don't know if i can name a movie in
the cars franchise
but cars is a movie right
but there's many parts like there's cars
part two
and maybe part three
thanks for the
the money i'm actually guessing
that was probably initially like foreign
currency
but then it was converted to us dollars
that's just my guess
wait is there a car's part two
i'm just not familiar with with that
franchise
okay let's uh win a queen
i'm guessing 1700
i have so many queens
2100
alexa
was i going to ask i forgot was i was
going to ask something
alexa tell me about cars
i don't know that one no i don't know
either
okay very similar opening approach from
the previous game
so f3 coming
oh oh thank you astro pickle for the
bits
position's kind of crumbling
i still like my position though some
attacking potential
okay we're gonna get some end game
i'm guessing 2200.
maybe 2300 that was a good move
losing a pawn black didn't take it
though
okay i'm guessing 2200
hell hey toilet what's up
oh no it's not toilets but hail to harry
krishnan
i should be winning this
black mr draw
oh 23.83 wow that's the second time i
confused you
oh yeah i think you did that last time
too
um yeah so what black should have done
in this position was push the pawn to g4
and then i have to chase it with my king
and then black's winning both of these
pawns
oh there's three movies cars cars two
and cars three wow
the first one is about a new rookie who
has to take hits to his ego
and gets a new mentor then there are
spies
and futuristic race cars
oh you donated 20 swedish krona oh
thanks so much
i was in sweden actually i was in sweden
back in
august august 2018
i was only there for like an hour i took
a ferry
over from denmark and got off the ferry
and had to go through passport control
i think i have some like swedish krona
coins
g cook gifting a sub
to an in that day
thanks for that wait i might have let me
see if i can find pictures from sweden
i can't find any sweden pictures i found
i found a denmark picture
this was denmark this is some um
castle in the distance
it's a nice place anyway
uh back to tournament
back to tournament i'm still undefeated
so zen so if you're just joining zen
mode is staying on
until i lose a game slightly unlucky
rating
okay let's play london again
what's the line here it just takes in c5
i don't know though just castle
yeah black's going for this oh
maybe this move before coming
or not
moving way too slowly this game
so i wanted to get the queen here
that's hard to do
also delete sleecha stopped us from
drawing
it's it's harder to draw illegal arrows
now
okay we have to trade queens
that didn't do anything
that's going to be a time scramble
[Music]
and arrows in rows and arrows okay back
to tournaments
life goes on
i think sorry christianity great and
thanks bitcoin boy
okay let's move on um just keep playing
i know the competition is getting
stronger
f4 is coming or not
i was writing that
i actually don't really know what to do
here
so i'm kind of just doing nothing
maybe c5
c5 is a blunder i could have taken in
knight b5
i want to play bishop f5
keeping the tension
i'm losing a piece
this could be my first loss and down on
time
i'm gonna fight though
[Music]
um
winning the queen
oh that's meat that's meat
wow oh
i was playing i would have guessed i was
playing a much stronger player
man i had almost
no time left
is joe in this tournament who's joe
there's probably a joe playing somewhere
we can we can actually check
jill yeah joe joe mar joe mark's playing
hasn't played the game yet though but is
registered
okay zen mode continues
my hands are kind of shaking
i'll play d5
okay i'm just trying to have like a
clean game recover from that last one
f7 is a bit tender
i want to keep my bishop here
more games than i care to admit has
ended with me
saying oh that mate hmm
it happens sometimes
if i'm hitting this pawn
i probably want to play e5 whoa what
does this move
a tricky move you can still play e5
there should be one so if i take the
knight black would take the bishop
now i can take the knight
whoa another donation is it more swedish
krona i don't know
thank you deuce thor
appreciate that oh obrigado oh that was
probably
brazilian what's the currency in brazil
rial obrigado is
oh that's also portuguese let's attack
stuff
wow it's not plunger anything
okay keeping keem
keeping it kind of clean kind of but not
really
um
oh says 10 and brl
yeah brl probably is brazilian real
and obrigado is portuguese
okay
i went to brazil once i played chess
sarah's um
the world u18 championships
okay going for the square
it's a nice kind of octopus
b4 was not a good move or was it
it's getting weird now
i think i'll take this and then c3
i just want to meet someday
or c2 someday
good move
moving way too slowly
[Music]
okay it's winning i have plenty of time
too
i was close though i got very low on
time
okay yeah i probably would have guessed
like 2300
this is my longest win streak lee chess
would probably tell me
i think my longest is probably over 20
games
happened at some point i'm pretty sure
i've played over 10 000 bullet games
on the chess
another stafford gambit that's streak
boy
this is probably the most common trap in
stafford
i'm going for bishop g4
let's not get punished
this is very very pleasant
this bishop just dominates everything
start with check the queen's getting
trapped
queen g3 bishop f4 bishops are
so nice together
wow another nice game
i would have guessed much lower rated
but it's the case like with these
opening traps
even high rated players can can fall
into them
okay yeah i'll look at my streak
probably
after this tournament
play uh an alvin counter gambit or not
alvin um [ __ ] beer counter gambits
this looks good for black
check
f5 is a move
take another rook i like damaging all
the rooks
and maybe the night
oh i have to be careful not to get mated
ooh be very careful
wait this is not so simple anymore
maybe it is i don't know
this is a very strange game
that's neat okay wow that's a really
weird game
man again i would not have guessed like
this high rated
okay i'm gonna try and finish as strong
as i've
been playing this whole tournament
another stafford gambit
this time declined
had this position earlier
unpleasant for black
knight d3 coming
i'm just going for the quick attack like
bishop here maybe rook here in here
also this move look at this move
knight e4 is a good good response i
guess
take that
i don't know if this is working for me
but i have to try it
oh this is definitely not working for me
but maybe this
check threading made in one
oh good move
check chuck meets
okay so white has king h2 here
i don't know what's going on in this
position it was a crazy game
i was interesting play
king h2 is black better oh box better
yeah but white one connect four
okay yeah just to address um this
queen's pinned
so that allowed me to to promote
uh back to tournaments
that's a nice streak hey about to break
100 maybe
play d4 again
what wait what i'm white i played d4
what's going on no
my streak what
what is this
why
my beautiful streak it's over
i got wrecked maybe it's because my
opponent was a gm
and lee chess was trying so hard to like
hide the zm
the gm title in zen mode that it
couldn't
cope with the enormity of the title and
the reading
and that cause server issues
i feel so salty now
i have to hydrate myself
that was like the worst possible way to
to end my streak
you don't go out with the bang but with
a fart
yeah whatever that means
i'm so sad i should just rage quit
i lost rating points too i i tried
playing d4 twice
and it didn't the move didn't register
maybe i just played the i tried playing
the london too many times
man
well
do i put that on youtube my best streak
ever
ends tragically
i was really sad